mettre la tête des gars dans mes seins
[Musique]
4000 francs
en plus
[Musique]
avec Stéphane Collaro dans les cocorico
boy de temps en temps avec Patrick
Sébastien je suis surtout quelques pubs
surtout avec Étienne
[Musique]
groseille
qui te ressemble et qui l'appelle
et qu'est-ce qu'ils disent les gens dans
la discothèque quand tu te vois c'est
quoi leur réaction
mitigé mais surtout que c'est courageux
de le faire
pour moi
[Musique]
que tu fais ça et que ça leur fait
je sais pas ils se disent pas non
mais ça leur fait je sais pas et dans
l'avenir
je suis en train de préparer un disque
et puis j'espère comme ça après prendre
un tournant sur la chanson
il a écrit
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu